so let me ask do you coordinate the
outfits ahead of an event cuz you guys
like all look really good together they
just like show up in the lobby and we're
like oh like you look right I think one
time we should just dresses the Blue Man
Group like shave our head no one will
not really coordinate this you look so
insane thank you that's obviously
seasoned new season coming out soon
we're weeks away season 3 is weeks away
any 19 days 19 days do you have a
countdown on your own oh yes I'm very
excited
why are you so excited is it the best
season yet yes oh my god what makes it
so good because it's like it does a good
job of like mixing the playfulness of
season one in the darkness of season 2
yeah everything's intensified it's just
a bigger cool it's cool and they just
the duffer's have just done so much for
the characters it makes such an amazing
way like honestly like my doing we
really do like really we're biased but
like we truly believe that it's a
fantastic season so we're excited guys I
got to tell you I mean we asked the Game
of Thrones cast a while ago is the last
season the best yet and they did not say
that so you feel very confident
wow yeah but they have a lot to go also
and also this might not be our last
season we don't know like 14 when would
you stop probably like 5 I think like I
think we should stop whatever the story
feels like it needs to be completed
there's no more story they don't really
need one more to like yeah one or two
more one or either one or two more have
you guys had those talks yeah no we
don't even think about we don't want to
be read Ross they're like oh we're not
telling you anything
yeah last questions for you guys just
tease the moment even if you can't tell
me all the details but what the moment
you're maybe most excited for people to
see the landing yeah the last two
episodes of my gross mind-blowing
yeah